correcto
esta campaña se necesita porque la
situación de los niños y jóvenes aquí en
canadá no es lo que uno espera para un
país que tiene los recursos económicos
que nosotros tenemos tenemos uno de cada
cinco niños vive en pobreza tenemos
niños que tienen problemas con obesidad
tenemos
niño un nivel de homicidios contra los
niños muy muy alto por un país como la
nuestra
y porque tenemos esas porque porque
canadá
está siempre allí en medio de los países
ricos
yo creo que durante ese última
generación hace 25 años
o tirado
los niños son el futuro de nuestro país
hemos pensado que solamente con un
desarrollo económico que todo va bien
para con los niños
y no es así hemos olvidado
las políticas públicas que necesitamos
como
un sistema mejor de preescolar un
sistema mejor
cuando una
hertha la luz que debe tener más tiempo
o el padre en casa con los cinco en el
niño hemos olvidado muchas cosas que una
sociedad necesita para que los niños y
los jóvenes sienten sienten feliz
sienten contentos sienten seguros para
que pueden crecer y cumplir con todas
sus posibilidades